I wanted to spend a moment talking about individual use cases.
Individual use cases are extremely valuable in understanding
expected user behavior.
They're also used in, in the development shops that
use agile methods in doing some of their planning and scheduling.
What it essentially is is a story illustrating a specific act,
interaction between a user and a system.
I've listed here a story about buying from Amazon.
It's written out as just narrative text.
And there's no structure to it, but nevertheless,
it's a way of expressing, in a very user centered form, a system requirement.
We could take this same story and also express it in a structured way.
Here in tabular form is the same story, in particular there are three columns,.
The column on the left is the actor, okay?
And there are two actors here, the user and the Amazon website.
There are various actions that could take place.
And sometimes, optionally,
there are objects, okay, that are used by the actor to perform the action, or
produced by the action, and those are in the right-most column.